il était attendu et a voulu se faire
entendre en une heure de discours jean
castex a détaillé la feuille de route du
gouvernement pour les prochains mois
avec plusieurs points clés
le premier ministre a notamment insisté
sur la crise sanitaire
s'il a voulu rendre hommage à son
prédécesseur edouard philippe
il a tenu également à faire comprendre
qu'un relâchement ne sera pas permis et
que pour cela de nouvelles règles
allaient être mises en place la
meilleure façon de nous préparer à une
reprise possible de l'épidémie est de
renforcer nos actions de prévention cela
passe nécessairement par le
développement du port du masque et une
intensification de notre politique de
dépistage
ce que nous devons par dessus tout
éviter c'est un retour à des formes
stricte et large de confinement dont
nous connaissons désormais le coût
humain et économique la crise sanitaire
a entraîné une crise économique et pour
tenter d'y remédier jean castex a fait
plusieurs annonces
le gouvernement a notamment prévu de
consacrer 40 milliards à la
reconstruction de l'industrie de la
france afin d'éviter une trop forte
dépendance vis-à-vis de ses partenaires
extérieurs après les résultats des
municipales
la question environnementale est devenue
incontournable et le premier ministre
l'a bien compris une relance verte est
de mise et l'exécutif entend concilier
pouvoir d'achat et transition écologique
le plan de relance proposera de
mobiliser plus de 20 milliards d'euros
pour la rénovation technique des
bâtiments thermique des bâtiments pour
réduire les émissions des transports et
de nos industries pour produire une
alimentation plus local et durable pour
soutenir les technologies vertes de
demain comme les batteries pour mieux
recyclé et moins gaspiller suite à ce
discours
les députés de l'opposition n'ont pas
tardé à réagir nombre d'entre eux se
sont empressés de critiquer cette
allocution et jean castex qu'il
considère comme nouvelle effigie du
maquereau nisme écoutez c'était aussi
long ennuyeux bourré de clichés que
prévu il ya une seule chose satisfaisant
puisque ça nous donne raison si dieter
idéologique c'est le retour de haut
commissariat au plan
maintenant il va falloir voir quelles
compte unis donne mais au moins ils
admettent ce que nous disons depuis deux
ans et demi cette volonté elle est
naturellement scène elle est même
indispensable mais pour valoriser les
territoires il faut des actes
on peut pas nous resservir pour la 44e
fois le développement du haut débit ou
la téléphonie mobile ou le maintien des
petites ligues ça nous l'attendions
mais qu'est ce qu'il ya derrière quelles
mesures concrètes
quel souffle quelles ambitions de
décentralisation je suis resté sur ma
faim
un discours qui n'a pas fait l'unanimité
mais qui a suffi pour obtenir une
majorité de soutien le premier ministre
a reçu 345 votes pour et 177 contre en
comparaison pour son premier discours de
politique générale edouard philippe
avait obtenu une large confiance de
l'assemblée nationale avec 370 vote
favorable bien plus que jean castex
[Applaudissements]